when you think of the greatest villains
in video game history
which series springs to mind the most
i'm betting it's far cry
and coming in february is the next
installment of that iconic series
again terribly sorry for what happened
[Music]
before
[Music]
did i ever tell you the definition of
insanity
hello and welcome to playstation grenade
once again i have teamed up with ubisoft
to hit you with another episode of
things you need to know
but this time it's all about far cry 6.
and as this is a sponsored video there's
a custom link in the description below
where you can find out more about the
game
so sit your butt down for 10 minutes
prepare to see a sausage dog in a
wheelchair
and let's do this perfect but useless
far cry 6 is based in the fictional
country of yara
a tropical paradise frozen in time even
though it's a completely made-up place
the links to cuba are evidenced
throughout from the 1950s cars to the
environment
from the inhabitants to the president
himself
but we'll get to him soon yara is an
island paradise but unrest has taken
hold as a revolution is forming
and we take control of a rebel and fight
to overthrow the might of the military
the open world here in far cry 6 is the
biggest in the series to date
so expect to sink some serious time into
this game next year each section of the
map is broken down into biomes
so expect to see picturesque beaches
dense jungles
and towns with npcs another great thing
of note is the capital city
esperanza this will be the home of our
enemy so i'm expecting this to be
heavily fortified
and if i'm honest i'm going to go there
straight away to find the hidden ending
we usually see in far cry games
remember in far cry 4 we could simply
sit still at the table at the start of
the game
to see an alternative ending please stay
right here enjoy the crab wrangle
or in far cry 5 in which we refuse to
arrest father joseph in the first five
minutes
boom alternative ending i can't wait to
see what that is
in far cry 6. well that leads perfectly
into my second point
the villain
[Music]
far cry 6's antagonist is the president
of yara himself
tasked with making the country great
again but this is done on the back
of those who oppose him making slaves of
protesters and competitors
are even worse still the story of far
cry 6 revolves around
el presidente anton castillo but he's
not alone here
i am president which means that someday
you will be el presidente castillo's son
diego is expected to continue in his
father's footsteps
making every second a learning
opportunity between father and son
including this moment when castillo uses
a grenade
to make a chilling point it has four
basic parts
the shell which contains the explosive
the fuse the handle
and of course the pin
what are you doing every far cry game
thus far has had a villain with
character and charisma
and an ideology which impacts us in
unexpected ways
the actors used over the years to bring
these characters to life reflect this
remember when troy baker was pagan min
this time
it's none other than giancarlo esposito
this guy
has been playing memorable characters
for years remember gus
in breaking bad what about moff gideon
in the mandalorian
however you know giancarlo you'll know
far cry 6 and the legacy of great bad
guys
is in good hands it'll also be
interesting to see if diego follows in
his father's footsteps
and by the way he's played by anthony
gonzalez who you may know as miguel in
coco
and let's get real for a moment if you
didn't cry at the end of coco
you may be in line to be the next far
cry villain
remember me
don't let it make you cry nope turn it
off
i don't want to cry
[Music]
let's move on to gameplay the series
formula is first person open world
exploration and combat
and that remains the call to this day
but this time
we're going to have full cut scenes
which will allow us to see our character
in all scenes this may not be a huge
thing to many people
but we usually see all events through
the eyes of the protagonist but
far cry 6 changes this and will
introduce more cinematic storytelling
opportunities
our hero and main character of the story
is danny rojas a military dropout who
finds themselves on the side of
revolution
and here's another nugget of info you
may like to know dany can be male
or female this follows on from the work
in far cry 5 to give us deeper options
and works similarly to the two avors
in assassin's creed valhalla male and
female i've noticed the trick here is to
give a name which is synonymous with
both sexes
and that's why my favorite name dave
will never work
if your name's dave please comment below
and i'll give you a digital
high five as dany is part of the plot to
overthrow the government
firepower is important but the rebel
budget
isn't as plentiful as castillo's arsenal
this means
impromptu weapons are here again just
like those in
far cry new dawn customizing and
evolving weapons
from unlikely everyday objects
flamethrowers return
but let's give a moment for this beauty
discos locos
a compact disc projectile weapon cds
flying everywhere i always thought
mariah carey's music was cutting edge
and now it's time to prove it dad jokes
far cry 6 will have many unique weapons
to find in the open world
the more ridiculous the better
one of the most important parts of
recent far cry games is the fangs for
hire system
in which we recruit an animal to be our
companion
remember boomer i mean before that word
was used to insult people
boomer was a good boy and attacked your
enemies whenever you needed him to it
fitted the u.s location really well
but now you are in yara and buma needs
replacing
and this is what the team chose meet
libertad chorizo
the freedom puppy who looks to have lost
the use of his back legs
but luckily he has a gladiator-style
weaponized wheels
and can carry enough ammo and mods to
keep the revolution burning
we will need to wait for the full reveal
of other amigos
all we know right now is that version of
the libertad charizo is a pre-order
bonus
i decided to research animals in cuba
and found crocodiles
serpents and many types of parakeet so
i'm calling it now
parakeet for hire there was a boy named
horatio in far cry new dawn
so my parakeet dream may come true
another brilliant thing you should know
about far cry 6 is the next
gen options when console generations
happen knowing if you're going to be
forced to buy a game twice
it's important info far cry 6 has been
confirmed to be a free update
which allows ps4 users to upgrade to ps5
without paying any extra cash
and the same thing happens on xbox smart
delivery over devices and generations
but of course you can't go between
platforms but if you decide to buy far
cry 6 for current gen
and then suddenly decide to get a ps5
you know the game will be able to come
with you
[Music]
another returning gem to the far cry
series has been confirmed in co-op play
if you haven't tried playing far cry 5
with a friend
i recommend it it's ridiculous in the
best ways
and thanks to the small print online we
know far cry 6 has it too
hallelujah if you're wondering what will
happen to the game after release you
should know that there is three lots of
dlc planned
and more to be revealed at a later date
inside the season pass
many of these can be picked up in the
pre-order bundles so let's quickly break
those down now
four additions have been confirmed
standard gold ultimate
and collector's editions like you'd
expect the standard edition is the base
game
whereas the gold edition secures the
three dlcs in the season pass
and from there the ultimate pack
includes more in-game items like a
crocodile hunter set
and get this an 80s style vice pack
complete with
hang on is that a is that a white
panther okay i no longer want the
parakeet amigo
i want that thing and finally there's
the collector's edition
which has a flamethrower a real
flamethrower
well a replica flamethrower you're not
going to start your own revolution
buying this
this edition is for the ultra fans with
the collector's case stickers and a4 art
book a steel book
soundtrack a map and even a disabled
chorizo keyring
so something for everyone that caring
though
that caring yeah i need that curing and
finally far cry 6 releases on february
18th
2021 it's so close releasing on ps4 xbox
one pc and stadia
with next gen confirmed to so now i open
this up to you what are your thoughts
on far cry 6 and would you be okay with
me covering this more in depth in future
when we find out more information
remember there's a link in the
description should you want to know more
i'm adam from playstation grenade it's
been a pleasure let me leave you with
one important question
who is the greatest villain you've ever
faced in a video game
it's a tough choice isn't it see you
next time
[Music]
you